[Music]
the loud house might make you laugh but
this family cartoon has had plenty of
moments that got the waterworks going
grab a tissue because the last one will
really have you crying don't forget to
hit that notification bell to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out the most emotional
loud house moments seeing the parents
face for the first time let's start with
an easy one the cartoon parents often
have hidden faces which helps the kid to
completely get away from adults as
they're watching their show the loud
house was no different
well at least up until the Christmas
special episode back in season 2 episode
1 the entire Christmas carol was really
touching but the best part came when we
finally got to see Rita's and Lynn
seniors faces it was definitely the best
kind of Christmas surprise but that not
even was the best part it's so cute to
see that this Christmas song was
actually Lunas idea and to be completely
honest it's totally awesome and it gets
better
we love that Clyde's entire family was
included in this seriously this is just
one of those touching cartoon moments
you have to see Plus this song will be
stuck in your head for the next few
hours
Luna really does start off this moment
in the best way possible and seeing the
parents face revealed at the end is just
that cherry on top to get your tears
going admit it you teared up when you
saw this scene
Lucy's lemons a lot of the saddest
moments actually have something to do
with pets so we've split them into three
points and we'll present them in the
next few minutes
the first one is Lucy's lament in season
1 episode 12 a we learned that Lucy has
a business she makes sure animals that
have passed away gets sent to heaven and
that I'd be honored to service funeral
director I keep an assortment of caskets
on hand of course things like that suit
Lucy's character but it's still pretty
sad when you think about it Lucy
actually holds a funeral for Lincoln's
class spider sure it might be just a
spider but this is just a reminder that
everything is a living bean she even has
a brochure and lets people choose the
casket shoe box or for a little more
money mahogany it's a little bit twisted
right but then again so is Lucy so
is pretty fitting jokes aside we bet a
lot of people can relate to Lucy's
determination to pay respect the past
animals kids always have a deep
connection to their pets it doesn't
matter whether they're smaller pets like
spiders or general ones such as cats and
dogs everyone deserves a proper send-off
don't they and Lucy's lament guarantees
just that sure Lucy makes sure she adds
some comedy to the mixed but the sad
message is still very clear missing pets
so let's dive in another sad moment that
involved pets what loud house does
really well is they showcase what kids
go through on a daily basis sure there's
some over exaggerated comedy thrown in
there but most of the time the stories
are pretty spot-on episode pet peeves is
one of those everyone can relate to
it'll hit you hard in the field
especially if you've lost a pet recently
it all starts when Lana brings home a
new dog which doesn't go down well with
the already established loud pets of
course they don't really receive enough
attention because everyone is
preoccupied with gushing over the new
dog after several attempts to get rid of
the new dog the pets decide to pack
their bags and call the pet sanctuary as
they leave they also managed to lock out
the new dog which means that all now
pets are now missing the most
heartbreaking scene comes from seeing
all the kids crying about their missing
pets seriously if you ever lost a pet
this is the episode that will get the
waterworks going this is one of those
episodes that shows the loud house isn't
all just about fun and games it also
touches on real situations
Lana's pet frog before we move on to
some other emotional moments we just
have to show you one more scene with
pets Lana has plenty of pets and in true
Lana's style most of them include
reptiles she even named her fly Brad's
because he lived in her pit get it Brad
Pitt's hilarious
but not everything is funny in the loud
house world meet hops
Lana's pet frog they met when Lana was
playing in a pond one day and created an
everlasting bond Lana actually gets
really upset when Lincoln says that
they're just frogs so there's no big
deal if he dissect them he's actually
really excited until
wanna tell him how horrible it is to
dissect frogs then she shows him how she
met her frog hops and honestly the
entire video made us a bit teary-eyed
Lani even calls hops her best friend and
in that video she shows Lincoln why you
should care for every single creature
this of course makes Lincoln change his
mind and he actually helps release the
classroom frogs isn't that just adorable
Lincoln is actually crying after he sees
Lana's video but we're sure he's not the
only one grab a tissue because we have
five more emotional moments to get
through Lincoln's birth story the theory
that Lincoln is adopted isn't only
limited to the internet world we've
heard numerous explanations why Lincoln
just looks so different from the rest of
his family so the season two episode 23
B came as a surprise because the loud
house actually addressed it while
Lincoln and Clyde searched through the
Attic they find Lincoln's baby book but
to his surprise his birth story page was
left blank Lincoln then goes to ask all
of his sisters to tell him about his
birth to much of his frustration they
don't really give him a confident answer
at that point Lincoln even begins to
doubt that he really belongs to the loud
family the true story shows that Lind
senior and Rita were on their way to the
hospital when their van broke down they
were in a complete shock when a black
limo pulled over next to them and to
their surprise it was the President and
the First Lady they weren't going to
make it to the hospital on time so
Lincoln was actually born in the
president's limousine which of course
makes sense because his name is Lincoln
although the actual story might not make
you that emotional this topic is touchy
for anyone who is on a journey to find
out where they really come from Lincoln
thinks he'll be kicked out okay this is
without a doubt one of those frustrating
moments that will make you tear your
hair out Lincoln really makes us feel
for him when he goes through the
emotional turmoil of thinking he'll be
kicked out of the house we all know
parents don't really pick favorites but
when Lincoln over here is that his
parents were planning on throwing one of
them out he gets worried of course he
didn't hear the part where the parents
were actually talking about Lynne
seniors ties they didn't actually mean
kids but you can just feel Lincoln's
sadness and confusion trash pickup as
he's doing whatever he can to make sure
his parents like him no child should
ever feel this way
but we have a feeling many do this is
just one of those important episodes
parents should watch with their kids and
make sure they tell them that they don't
pick favorites the way Lincoln reacts to
what he overhears and how he is visibly
distressed will definitely get those
waterworks going poor Lincoln he really
doesn't seem to catch a break does he
Ronnie Ann moving away the loud house
fans have a love/hate relationship with
Ronnie Ann on one hand she's an
absolutely hilarious character and we
loved the relationship she has with
Lincoln but on the other most of us also
remember the bullying Lincoln had to
endure and it was just because she
didn't know how to tell him that she
actually likes him but this episode hits
close to home especially if you've ever
had to move and leave your friends and
everything you know behind is never easy
and Ronnie Ann had the experience
firsthand season 2 episode 13 gives us
an insight into Ronnie Ann's family
including the extended family that lives
in Great Lake City everything goes fine
until Ronnie in figures out that their
mom actually wants them to move there
this of course means that Ronnie would
have to leave everything behind
including her friends it's even worse
because Ronnie Ann finds out this news
just when the weekend ends and the
family is supposed to go back home
seeing her upset is honestly one of
these saddest moments ever anyone that
has ever left anything behind in the
process of moving can relate luan giving
up comedy words often hurt especially if
they come from someone you care about we
all know Luanne sometimes got overboard
and can be a bit annoying with her puns
and pranks but family members sometimes
just have to deal with that
unfortunately sometimes enough is enough
and you just have to rant about how you
feel in an episode called no laughing
matter
Luanne overhears those rants and
realizes just how much her family
members hate her jokes it seems very
clear to her that she gets on their
nerves so she decides to drop her
passion I wish she would just stop
[Music]
yep she decides to quit comedy while
that would definitely make the loud
family members to feel more at ease they
can see how this decision affects LuAnn
since comedy really is her passion
deciding to quit it actually means she's
deciding to quit a part of her
personality so naturally her character
changes and she just isn't fun anymore
the kids realize that and they decide to
try to get the old Luanne back of course
everything ends in a happily ever after
because this is a kids show after all
but the message is still important
talking about something behind their
back it can sometimes lead to terrible
consequences mr. grouse is family the
loud house gave us many important
lessons including the one about getting
to know someone before you judge them we
all have that one person we know that we
just don't like they might be grumpy all
the time or they might constantly
complain mr. grouse is known as the
grumpy next-door neighbor that doesn't
really like seeing the loud kids have
fun but there seems to be a reason why
he's so grumpy and we learned that in an
episode called eleven loud the leapin
Lincoln ends up finding out more things
about mr. grouse after he finds himself
in his house it turns out that mr.
grouse has a family that's about the
same size as Lincoln's family but unlike
Lincoln he can't really visit his family
as much as he wants to it's like this
scene comes straight out of the home
alone movie it's the same episode with
the loud parents actually reveal their
faces so you bet you're going to
experience a lot of emotions with this
one it's a perfect one to rewatch as
you're getting ready for Christmas if
that didn't get you going grab your
tissues because the very last moment
will definitely get those waterworks
going L is for love kids have crushes
and often they're afraid to reveal who
it is it's rare that cartoon shows
embrace the LGBT community but the loud
house is different LGBT characters like
Clyde's parents have been very much
appreciated the one episode and one
moment really made us cry L is for love
is a controversial episode that's
actually been banned in a few countries
the reason it has LGBTQ characters and
countries with controversial views
weren't happy about that we bet we
weren't the only ones that were
emotional when we saw Luna revealing
that her crush was actually a girl we're
so proud of the show and the character
for this moment we all
love how the loud kids empowered Luna
and convinced her to tell her crush how
she feels and when she did revealing
that Sam was a girl just made it that
much more special this just further
proves that the loud house is more than
just a comedy style cartoon you can
actually learn a lot from watching this
show and you'll definitely have a few
tear-jerking moments what do you think
what's the saddest ever loud house
moment come let us know in the comments
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]